so I guess there's no body introducing
me so hi Jessica give your self
introduction my name is Kwame we are
working in this department for doing
calculation of biology at the by for my
wife America's data analysis and also we
are building this software called a reco
which is that particle path with
knowledge base so it's a title here
today actually is a quite a big so I hid
differently
I saw the I get here give me you guys
that gen general no introduction about
heroes in retro for systems budget
they've had neurosis but it seems like
it's just a too much so today I'm going
to focus on two topics the first thing
is just a gentle introduction about this
project saying is about it's one's basic
seven project that we are working on
called a reactive functional attention
network so the project we have been
working on for almost twenty years
so there are a lot of things we actually
I actually had talked about maybe for
several days or sometimes several weeks
so bad in this thirty minutes I'm going
to try of folks are nearly give you some
introduction level talk so okay so
before I introduce the rectum pathway
database up we call the password
knowledge base I'd like to talk about
why we need the pathway based at 800
data analysis and five pathway database
so why do we either persuaded her
analysis so here is the motivation
example about six or seven years ago a
similar research group
beings award a performer so-called a
pan-cancer data analysis and a founder
this 2:127 cancer gene cancer genes they
are mutations actually people are in no
king can cause coma development so here
is a list of this 127 cancer drugs
cancer genes so from here
you can see is what came actually you
can see you're basically cannot see
nothing so we really don't know what
these drinks we know what these jeans
look like of course we know their names
but we don't really know what their
function is why is he a beauty drinking
actually called humor development of
causing cancer so so how can we really
understand their functions and YZF
mutation can cause cancer so here our
article pathways come to the rescue
so our all possibly be the data analyst
basically a project a list of genes like
127 cancer drug trees or to past week
hottest thing give us give us the court
has to link all these things together to
see or what are these things to see what
other genes function so basically the
first one is it can help us try to
visualize gene Soucy billing island they
did it in pathway context so this G's
can come from so called the French
searching expression analysis if you
guys that come from computational
biology water so you have done I believe
you should have done a lot of these
conduct analysis or they come from this
so called the Jim was that is for Jindal
wide Association study so from G wise we
can get a list of cicadas significant
snips
saying can be mapped or chinks and get a
list of significant gene and also he can
come from epigenetic analysis okay so as
I said by project Aziz seemingly
unrelated things on two pathways
basically we try to understand some
mechanism why are these things hard so
the most likely some of the genes
mission is similar functions under by
doing pass within tonight so we can also
try to increase that another sipar
eyelid using the theta
so actual data complexity from like
several solid strings originally you may
have a lot of second differences saying
okay i treemap it was
100 G's so you have some kind of
so-called a dimension reduction and also
provided functional context
so which kala so-called explain enteric
hard to understand all these biology
implication yeah you can ask questions
whenever your ha ha ha ok we should have
enough time because algebra it is for 30
minutes like now I have 60 minutes for
me
ok so several years ago a group I
believe in UCLA somewhere
so the first author is hi catcher
si si generalized our pathway based the
data that is approach into this so
called a three-generation even the view
people publish that you pass
computational biology 2012
so the first generation is so called
over the president his nanites for a
basically was development of for tweak
for doing the fresh expression analysis
so from the pressure gene expression it
on Isis you can get her list of
significant genes by so-called the
hottest rich holder so you get a disease
so you do some kind of very simple
statistical analysis and try to figure
out what the pathways are significantly
enriched of significant technology there
are a plethora to use instead of the
cheeks so this is but the first
generation of causal enrichment is
called o ra so as you can see here this
approach is he Edith Wilson hardest rich
order to pick up a list of second
victories so there are a lot of
information different race lost so
people come to this second degeneration
pathway nice color functional class
calling or FCS
so exist exist this generation of
analyticity use the technique consider
every
statistic is an azalea develop some
hands that is to the test the most
popular one is this generation so called
at GCSE a burgeoning state college
mathematics which is really really
probably the most popular husband
illegitimate and nice even like the
present
so from here but it steals they are
something as you can see if you know
some pathways of possibly actually there
are a lot have to crawl it topological
structure is something like something's
activated on Street jimmies are some
things inhibitor or activate all these
carnal relationship
so the first generation approach the
biskits don't consider this very very
very rich information so people come
with this so-called past with hope
logical pace today tonight
so try to consider this kind of product
topological structure including number
of reactions positional forgings
approaching x' and what type of flash is
involved so one of most of what is a
quadratic my tree one of approach
developer hood for bait for this past
with project-based approach is called
spi a for signaling for the bay tree
analysis ok from here
so all these three generations yeah our
base pairs is so-called a pathway
database so from here you can see a
pathway database basically is the
foundation for to eat all kinds of parts
we need analysis so it's a indispensable
resources for this so come back to
wrecked home so currently but we fear
multiple has within our base available
the silly most popular pathway database
of course we have talking about reactor
so in the rectum probably is the most
popular one it is open source open
access there's not any constant granted
to use rectal so things are second this
actually probably the most popular one
for experimental biologists that will do
positive time is called a keg but I
unfortunately
originally was open sauce you can have
you can you could have unlimited the
exit to that but because of some kind of
funding issues but the seven or eight
years ago says he seen either paralyzing
so in order to catch Donald as their
content of from their FTP side but yes
as that user you can still access the
content on a several web-based a service
from keg I using their website or
restful api so the last one I'd like
point out is called a wiki pathway so
that we could possibly see uses this
weekís die online editing tools so
basically you can editing or pathways
provided by weekly possibly online
kinetically so they use all this wicked
style trap try to track him all this
edit in history so it is quite useful
but there's a problem is the things said
go here for the same in child
represented resources but it
unfortunately biologists seems not that
we're willing to do all these community
service because I guess they are just
too busy okay so come back to recomm as
I said electron is open source open
access hospital hobbies or all content
expert expert the author the manually
curated and the purely viewed so the
bottle ninety just died as I said is we
are very very difficult to recruit
external biologists who do some curation
for us in a timely way and a high
quality way so but since we are doing
our best try to lay Craig data from all
these experts okay
and our pathways in reto actually
supported by I original experimental
evidence they can be traced that with
primary literature currently we have a
note here across to the
the thousand published literature offers
so that is quite a lot so the data in
retina sedate hang retro is extensively
cross-reference to external by
informatics al-khaimah immigrant
informatics database so as the community
resource this is very important so
people can cause reference together and
see what actually happened so in
imagining the future if they are some
cannoli early artificial intelligence on
machine learning
horror system so they can cause all
together to generate a unified that
knowledge systems work for users so we
also do some so-called a computational
inference try to infer pathways from
human as a no human model organisms of
the menu focus the manual curation the
focuser for manipulation is our human
pathways so we crack all these
experimental evidence from experimental
system for human biology so but in order
to reach to a wire the research
community we do this curve so-called
connotation or inference and also along
with the data we also provide a suite of
user intuitive high-performance software
tools for user to browse our content and
perform some parsley basically
technologies so I'm going to show you
more about these questions okay
so rectum basically is a so-called
ration network database so the
foundation of our notation is about
chemical Reggie so the biochemical ratio
is basically your networking or data
model so that sir so this relation means
the data model actually is very flexible
and the melissap higher it can be used
to and not hidden almost all biological
process currently people have found from
molecular at the molecular levels inside
a cell or between cells so this is great
and according to Ballad chemistry we are
not here are alleging as set of inputs
convert it into a set of outputs and
this collagen came beleaguered by the
goraishi so this Nagar Asia including
activation or intubation and of course
this is about chemical agents should be
and not headed by some kind of catalyst
so we have this little so-called
catalyst activity so as you can see here
all objects are not here the for
reaction and also reaction itself is
external extensively cross linker to our
external database as I just hold out
several slides ago so here is example
about is I chemical ration of a notation
these are basically unit or everything
we we are not here is based on a stop
back and creation so I just show you one
specific example so example is has base
eight activation PID bike River G so
this is a 1 1 1 reactions occur in
apoptosis so from here you can see the
original protein the ID has Canarsie
has 195 I mean no residues
so this proteins a terminal peptide that
can be
read about this so-called active hospice
8 which is a peptide so create the limo
of the egg criminal 61 having no
residues I mean no as the reduced to
activities project so here so as you can
realize this we provide early early
techno detailed mechanism about this
how this protein activate another
protein compared to another pathways
which is K so you you can see the
difference between our reactant and the
cake is in care what is the other hitter
is it just have this simple relationship
is functional actually functionalisation
the jealousy are caspase-8 are activated
by ideology and they okay so we actually
provided met yes molecule details
curators the peer review like when the
biological we think this reaction
happens in the human cell yeah like do
they say like what context should they
learn that from like what yes I think
it's probably the same biological yes
this is the actually is like that yes
this is the liquid question so the
majority of all the supporting evidence
come from human based experiments but is
there still some of comments actually
come from no human base the experimental
evidence for example like you said some
ovulation come from
maybe East or maybe moss so we use this
so-called a sequence of horrible trying
to play big hit it if this reaction
happens in Mars can we actually see if
there's a counterpart in human and as in
we predicted so we so of course all
these becomes an accommodation
prediction so it's the actual confidence
is really a bigger question yeah but
that's just as a state of Zod yes okay
so the reason is why we want to do this
is because when we see there are some
human reactions exist and others in and
as a humorous and as an artist another
and so the a circle kept existing so we
can borrow all this no human
experimental evidence try drilling
causes
which came out there's a like her I
evidence CRT is possible because wisest
happen to this also happened and so
different is there something can exist
so okay
no questions no okay
so so come back a tool or an adhesion
gear so from here you can see one
rations output here can be used as a
input or catalyst or literacy
unnecessary actions so therefore by
using this approach we can connect all
these relational together to form a
reaction based network so pathways in
loyalty to basically is a set of edges
connected to each other like say suing
so our conference in reactor can be
literally the presenter as a single
relational network for human or as a
species think it's a projector to the
ratio based the data analysis and
visualization so pathways in red from
actually are organized in a hierarchy
like here a past we can have separate
pathways inseparable pathways but
allagadda lists at as a bottom the
bottom levels is composed of biochemical
ratio only so here is example a but as a
highlight Co structure or for human cell
cycle pathway so you can see that
highlights co stretch is quite a
complicated so it can have multiple
levels so the flexibility of our data
model based on reaction RA is very good
so it allows us to describe all
different kind of election types and the
pathways for example all pathways can
cover metabolism signal tradition or de
Bourbon biology cell cycle DNA damage
and they'll appear and also stress
response or data model can also be
actually are not hidden disease pathways
so currently we have a disease pathways
we use this so called SBG in for systems
biology crud not wishing to draw up a
sweet diagram so we have a set of
standard complying the diagram key
displayed here and it draws is was well
show you what bothers is okay so to
allow user tweaks to explore our past we
content we have this software to cut a
path through browser which provide the
features for users to browse our
pathways so so the user can view the
path we highlight structure here can
view the actual ela biology stuff
readily appealing pathway diagram for a
selected pathway for for example this is
the pathway diagram for caspase
activation viewer increasing apoptosis
to canary so withdraws it so it is
almost a publication quality so however
everything is openness so you can
actually Electra side this as long as
your point of this I do tell from
reactor so it's fine okay so this is we
call this is enhance the high level and
the view so if you draw drill down so
you can actually see detailed chemical
reactions the only try to understand the
biochemical mechanism as displayed here
so this is example so come back to that
my example chemistry bad chemical
reaction here so when the user selected
what this one specific a pathway so you
can see that a simple text that Hakka
bond is the reaction of Hathaway and she
can check out as a knowledge and on
literature of friends we use it or not
here it is parking garage this page
displayed here and also we provide a
list of proteins or small molecules or
whatever we have are not hidden forces
selected by chemical a sheet sometimes
there's a mother since again it's like
so you can always see all this PETA the
information at the bottom here so this
the jet example so therefore see a for
proteins are trained involve the users
conference why it's your only for food
okay that's very strange
oh sorry actually two proteins involved
easiest direction so here you see these
two proteins involved in this Reggie
actually a highlight here in the front
the colors it's very difficult to see
here but they are 38 proteins total
forces the spread of pathways so that is
this number means 2 and above 38 ok so
if there are some protein 3d stretch a
variable so our users can also view all
these 3d structures by link by linking
to external PDB which is for protein
data bank so they provide others Christo
schedule so by doing this basically we
can get some kind of really really
Moloch Roy details about how these two
proteins they are indebted to each other
with our like Jose's peptides this
enzyme catalyst in terminal so there's a
molecular mechanism people you can try
to figure out so we also provided this
so-called expression at class so we pull
data from data was called expression
Atlas hosted a European bile phonetics
Institute
so for each individual proteins see they
provide expression levels in different
tissue types here this is this column I
chip the venetie type societal proteins
for this specifically about calculation
so they are not widely published people
can really try to see or if these two
proteins are actually expressed in some
tissue under getting some ideas if this
about chemical reaction actually
possibly happen so I actually have to go
back more step so our puzzle is actually
click the from all different a type of
tissues or cell type C so what you what
do you see here
supposed to happen some pasta to happen
differently in different tissue types
but what you see is all these collected
so we in as a ward
we don't have pictures specific
impossible activity or different
features specifically available right
not yet but we are working on that okay
so so even after almost 20 years and not
Haitians the coverage of our database
deals along like 50% of total human
genes so there are still a lot of things
we we have not we have not are not
heated or there lot of things we haven't
we really don't know first of college
there's no actual experiments performed
to do that or they are actually these
proteins may don't have h of function so
for as a website as a web application we
also try to increase our coverage of the
human genome by encoding protein code he
intubations on to our puzzle diagram so
we use this so-called psychic web
service which is a standard provided the
Pfizer protein-protein interaction
community to provide to provide a
standard a format for people to do all
these supporting protein network based
technologies so we use this service and
the overlay protein-protein interaction
or to a pathway diagram by doing this
basically we can increase our coverage a
lot if it's a protein protein original
protein-protein interaction data said
can cover for example like a 95 percent
of all human genes so we basically
Ozzy's so currently there are a lot of
cyclic based service available so we can
pour all this service individually from
this and I Tricia almost like a civil
similar
feeling not very sorry yeah several
hundred the meanings of PPI
protein-protein touching a variable
cause well there's different distortions
so that's a lot this is a very valuable
soft okay yes
one either tissue-specific or to
incorporate data from alternative
splicing of proteins or is it this is
essentially just you know yeah one
protein yes
which encompasses all the variations of
potential alternate splicing and
whatever tissue it happens to come from
right so we fully aware of this issues
so what one project current her actually
have one overlay features we have
developers try to over a tissue space
which expression theta or thought his
past with diagram so they give you the
same kind of ideas on what actually
happened with all this broad keep these
things at a specific pattern so they can
get us sense of tissue specific
information another project is one of
our PhD students Josh so he is not here
he's tried to develop some machine
learning approach try to use this
general like a pathway for our tissues
try to really influential specific
information and the regarding visual
specific isoforms we are not here some
some earliest small subset of proteins
for their isoforms but not as a tissue
specific but as a problem is with this
issue specifically so forces right now
they are not many information especially
experimental evidence of variables so
people do not have this is the largest
skill or McLean had analysis try to see
all these isoforms
so this is more like a competition of
biological issue it's not a little ear
manipulation issue so it's not all
you wanna see something cracy no okay so
as I said the ego web-based the tools we
also provide the features to help users
to heart to pathway in Richmond
tonalities this actually is the first
generation pass really to meta-analysis
so it's not that much but it is really
popular and can give our users a lot of
password based information for the
re-uploaded written list we in addition
to enrichment and I see we also provided
this so-called species comparison and
the jinx plays you overlay under
visualization so how the species
comparison is basically we can compare
two pathways for example between human
and the Easter see or what rashes exist
here in human and the water issues Missy
in East so by doing this you can we can
get a lot of Vichy especially for people
use all this model algorithm to do
experiments yes
and then you said that 50% of human
genes are annotated and react on like in
the actual wrath ways
has anyone do you know if anyone is like
actually has looked to see whether like
I know a lot of these protein-protein
interaction networks they have like a
magnitude like how likely are some some
like it is numeric yeah sensation of how
likely that protein interaction is and
whether like the that whether they like
that number actually correlates with the
genes that show up in react to them as
part of your voice yeah someone's done
that yes okay yeah so we trade the
psychic communion here they also provide
a sometimes go to scores is protein
protein energy so we can use this course
to disparate here unfortunately the name
is Krisha or the cutter this control
here so there should be a scope attached
of each port important for the energy so
we can look at not filtering and the
selected sort of protein protein touches
yes yeah well conference yeah yeah
yes yes yeah yes this kind of way yeah
okay
okay so so here is a feature for doing
protein rich metal noises so let's think
come back to our original 100 and they
can lead ravages so here is the results
for doing possibly enrichment analysis
for these 102 nism and cancer drug
cheese and you can see there are a lot
of pathways in red when I reach them so
this is the ones oh this is the one
specific house we call secured by uber -
so here so we should we show that actual
p-values FDR values and also genes come
from that specifically lists are
highlighted in this pathway diagram so
you can really see all we will see
actually involved in this pathway
diagram I do this
currently you can actually only manually
check things that in the future we would
the represent a mathematical model into
can really do this automatically right
now say see what each individual
militaries can cause a positive a change
which will be the happy partners okay so
for the power you so previously I talked
about all these web-based the features
but the for the power users who may not
necessarily want to use react on
web-based tools we can also download the
pathways and the inpatient data using
different data formats so I have talked
about SPG sidekick so we also supported
these power packs which is the current
community standard flow people here in
pathway data and also this is B ml which
is the standard for system biology for
people do a lot of mathematical models
so we can actually explore the uphaus
ways into SPM a SB ml format so the
using things they can load into CSP ml
place the mathematical model into Lissa
to do whatever they like to do allowance
this
they'd have format we also provided rest
of our API based her web service so
people came to like a call our web
service and try to integrate our service
into their certain software pipeline so
we have spent a lot of time trying to
kill all web service performance so it
is quite a high performance so that it
actually is great
so in case you are curious the whole we
are a to an adhesion so here is a
pipeline this this side is very simple
pipeline how we actually do many
curation
so basically will accrue the external
biologist we call them authors we can
use a software to cut also to or
decongestant use Microsoft Word or
PowerPoint see are not hidden pathways
by which we actually Questor by us or
they can also providers taught top use
by themselves in Xia purely us easier
and not reaching they should have
provide links to external database for
example if they are not healers
unfortunately should link to Unicode and
also they should provide the
experimental evidence which we should be
primary literature reference for all
assertions describe the inferior
pathways and as in all internal pureness
will work with this external authors and
the user software who had a curative
trailer to make sure the content these
authors are not hated the consistence
with our data model and we also use
software to do is your qualities and
make sure our comment consistent and
this process may goes through several
steps between journals and authors
before actual final lists we also ask
external another set of external biology
to do purely view so as you can see is a
process is just like I do
application so I don't this week really
trying to ensure high quality for the
community so be virtually Lisa we use
that to cut a slice - slice to release
really content into a production
Savannah's equal to another like a set
of software - to get a continent it's a
final web application
okay so assembly we have developer a
bulk pass with called erect home so
users can access and read home based on
its website and web RESTful API based
rest of all each had based web service
and as he can also tell this data based
on Civello community standard standing
the file formats they can also perform
as we build the data analysis in your
website and the content and the software
totally open there's no the strength to
use the all content and a software in
either academic or industry settings so
so so do impossibly based data analysis
is great but is there still some problem
so two obvious issues here is one in
reto as you remember hopefully our
pathways are organized in a holic way so
this may give us some kind of issues for
example so a chaud for the from or
illegitimate analysis edge list is that
table like here for this word read
listen we get the drive but if you just
focus on this for pathways they actually
present in the same tree branch that
when you actually do this when you will
not really deal eyes oh what is the
relationship here you have to go back to
the actual original hierarchical tree so
we have tried the web some kind of
really user ensured have software
software features address this kind of
problem but as the you can see it is
still very difficult from this table
list to this hierarchical try to really
understand why these four pathways there
are hot or significant heat so this is a
one issue the second issue is our
pathway is actually a lot of possibly
inside the cell they're cross-linked by
shearing same proteins and all cheering
same set of fractions all auto from
wooden pathways can actually grow past
activities of another pathways so this
kind of across all these cross link that
personal relationship so for example
this to passivate second by fz-fi
or secured by SDF keep so both are same
actually start stippling and not heated
and a signature that she has me which
means they are actually two different
type of signal pathways but as the
question is why these two pathways that
are both hit by this word you listen
carefully
so from here you basic here not really
and so this type of question so what we
can do so is this is just
summary about these two issues and if
you are in this field so you're
different
are we really so cotton network base to
date handle assist so it's a network of
a state attorney alike and not as
basically is to try to perform system so
why the biological house we need
analysis or in this case we should not
only the cop has me different which the
Lily called
network based with analysis so network I
used the pies this approach cover a lot
of things usually cover over 50 percent
of our human genes and currently is a
network were used for this type are not
as serious coding protein tell you
network and of course there are a lot of
she inspirational variable / - is that
so people you use a lot of network based
the algorithm they try to find the
modules also called clusters try to find
a network of parties so after they found
out all these network modules they can
do some kind of functional and what
he/she based on that analysis they also
based on that they can try to real
advantage in signatures for
discovery and by using this the king
actually see as you can see if there are
some mule disease genes can be found
from Saudis network I tried to find a
for example find a killer job cheese or
other diseases yes yeah
if you identified a gene that had a very
in termination that you want to analyze
and it happens to be high up in the
hierarchy so you know as you move down
it may influence you know 1516 terminal
yes reactions is there a best practice
or a good what's the best way to
describe that pathway do you just go up
until the the point where the gene
exists and then use the name for
whatever that larger you know route the
pathway is or is there is there a best
practice for that so that you don't get
to the point where you're including
every single reaction just because this
one gene had a so you mean what he
actually means their upstream genes the
mutant you can affect a lot of
downstream reactions right yeah so that
is what I'm talking right enough okay
see we needed to use this network based
approach okay yes right yes okay
so two issues so the first one is the
hierarchical so what we can do basically
just each other to fractionate is
passive income on single network so in
your case most likely these upstream
interactions will sit on that top of
this whole huge network so then you by
doing all these network paster traverse
so you can find out what the downstream
part
don't ruin righteous will be so if I do
this you can easily find a possible
impact of directions for that
specifically of course because the
network itself is very very calm
preceded by lupus so maybe some
downstream villages may not be affected
by the mutating because there's some as
a loop okay okay the second the past
week hearts talk is about it that issues
with past we cross talk so basically if
we put all this protein or genes in the
same network so everything or possibly
our proteins will be displayed only one
single networker so in theory there
should have been no such issues at all
and if that crosstalk coming from
integers so they are always displaying
the same network okay so in order to
support a network based approach in the
later project we have developed method
to construct a function intelligent
network from an inhibitor pathways in
rectal so basically what we did is we
try to convert a reaction into a set of
functional relationship the member
reaction is a basic unit if we can do
this so it is possible we can convert
the whole pathways into a pledging
network into a functional integer
relationship and network under sometimes
the some compressed involved in
biochemical ashes of when we have a
compress we also do this pairwise cover
basically convert all these
subunits into pairwise meditation so by
these two steps basically can convert a
pathway into a setup okay so here at his
example originally for this specific
biochemical agent after this comedy it
come to lead singer so it's just like a
kettle right now so but the cake the
intention cake actually is separated for
each individual pathways so what I'm
talking right now is to create a single
Network covers our pathways are not
hitting record dynamics so the actual FI
network we use the HV is moseying
extractor functional intention from a
non hidden layer to pathways why we want
to that basically we try to really
increase the coverage of our network try
to Li provide a comprehensive network
resource for the community to network
based of internationalization so we
developed this software pipeline in
addition to lighten we also extract
functional relationships from CAG pencil
pass away xti niche pathway NC about cut
and we also manually in creator to PF
target antigen datasets to support each
integral to a network and we also used a
very simple machine learning approach
called an IE basic classified try to
collect all these pairwise relationship
if audience in who machine learning
approach and we use extracted a
functioning trashing to train and
validator not if it's in classified so
the final fo network a tray contains two
tripods advice one is extracted which we
should have been regarded as the highly
reliable if I and another one is
predicated so we use some threshold and
try to pick up only highly advise with
very high scores okay so we build our fr
network every year the current version
is
2018
she was the Builder in December 2008 him
so here is a number so we did save a
network cover about 13,500
for the human genes which is about 6%
and covers the 431,000 functioning
veggies and a compared to our current
Elise which is analyse 69 so it covers
about her 11,000 so they are 24 % g
coverage ok so we have a developer some
approach try to use this red fr network
so that first I'm going to show you
several examples the first one is we can
use the red in fat that work for
visualize issue so for example we can
project this so they will hunt
so the 341 mutated genes from this 9150
vehicle breast tumor sample and that map
to fr network there are 70 percent and
the say in contract is if our network is
it for this map genes after that we do a
network cluster analysis and of furnaces
two modules anything we do possible
enrichment analysis and itching on
totally German and ice and a fondant
exists this module the first module I
trade a significant delay in which the
genes inside the plasma as the membrane
cytoplasmic husband memory and the
cytosol and as this second module which
has the 50 genes actually significantly
to the genes in nucleus so you can
imagine a trade you don't need any magic
so jinxing this path will lead a second
transmission pathways since it is
possible to being a hero
chromatin mechanics so we did some kind
of statistic and knowledge and a founder
some majority 84 percent agree over
stroma having mutations in both of these
modules which is a change
so which day was a patient should have
bill teachings in both of this different
type of genes or different of pathways
in order to really having tumor
development so we also use this Ethernet
we'll try to do some kind of incident
discovery
this is gene discovery to do that we
basically for each string so we
calculate some kind of so called
cheating ranking score for cancer gene
ranking score by using public available
on rankings go from Memorial
sloan-kettering and a check sighing
scores for each cheating's based on say
our neighbors and saying we come here
the origin of positive dataset and the
random date has data on the [ __ ] and
find the drug things actually having
higher average rank who they know they
saw this one we can develop some time
machine learning approach under nearly
predicted if sink resemble the last
example I'd like to talk is we also use
this lately fact that work for Network a
signature discovery so all generally
remember or if a network edges so-called
and we'd hidden on a fun network saying
we can try to assign expression
correlations as the way to with Network
twelve and width and commodities and
with the fo network answer with network
saying we subject this with the network
to with sensitive network Christine
algorithm like here is called MCO
for Mack graph clustering so then we got
a set of modules under the uses the
modules as a gene signature to do some
some data analyzer so in this case we
use the ones basic module actually is
the first module with develop our
samples into two groups the first group
having high expression
second high expression values in this
module
saying it's a second group so as you can
see you
five independent breast cancer data sets
we can't get a very significant p-values
from survival analysis so here's our
actual cheating thing about things this
module we use the for this for the uses
of our nurse analysis so you can see
based on our functional enrichment
analysis so this module enriched Jenks
involved English so called Lola ISKCON
during an SSI claim face and over asking
to gradually later two chromosome
maintenance so it is always limited to
so both of them I traded her cell
proliferation so it totally makes sense
because high expression here means the
highs their profession so there is less
short okay so we compare a skillet with
or as a published breast cancer
signature and the kcra3 signature
performs outperform or other published a
signature based on these five
independent therefore a scarcity does it
so much which is good so come back to
our original 102 days 7 cancer drugs
drive cancer drive so we did it same
thing and then create if I stop and
network anything see what actual
function already so we got four modules
is this module is the little cell cycle
see p53 some secondary pathway and and
as I said hot screen pathway so this is
actually is this thing which harder to
answer it's the first question we placed
about the partial crosstalk so I just
zoom in a little bit so this you can see
secondly by FGFR and a signal Reba SPF
kid genes involved as he posted in the
same module so no wonder why the same
these two pathways actually hit parties
100 reasoning cancer drug chicks because
they actually probably most of the image
is the same yeah
that's impossible but used as different
ways or they got some hot language but
Allah coddle is say ah [ __ ] okay so okay
so I have three more slides so I
finished
so in summary based on like to pass away
we have contracted a functional
interaction network so reaction function
vintage Network can be used for data
visualization this is gene prediction
network based extinct discovery and and
the pistol rectum possibly underlaid
with a network with developer app called
a ride home f5 is for cider skid pad
because you don't know cell escape so
silent escape probably is the most
popular standard and launched other
application for biological parcel for
the logical network visualization and
data analysis so with development status
ad for this software underway implement
a lot of features to help our user to do
network and a path so it basically
tonight's that visualization so this is
just a subset of this because this is
based on a paper with published in five
years ago so there are a lot of new
features available ok so if you'd like
you can check out a part from this side
escape app store so and if you want to
know more you can also check out of this
so this is my final conclusions and see
here so this ability other take-home
message we're not go step by step okay
so finally it is my acknowledgment so
the project is supported by NIH formal
and they yes and also it is supported by
you know Canada or Korea is on types of
Ontario province and is joined the
project with a group in EB I so it is
also supported by Europe
so this is the whole list of him
currently working on the project and
Steve oh here he is our summer intern is
working to integrate a machine or
natural language processing technique
into accurate who try to really help our
children for some kind of automatic
calculation so that's it questions four
minutes left yes first thank you that
was amazing talk I think it's a great
resource it's gonna become more and more
useful as informatics developers come up
with innovative approaches to use this
this awesome day that you guys have
created but I wanted to go back briefly
to the idea of predictive modeling that
was touched on in a couple questions and
slides and the idea that you might use
this data to predict downstream
consequences of perturbations in some
upstream reaction or gene or vice versa
if you have an outcome of interest
predicting what upstream events might
result in that and that outcome so a
particularly a concrete use case I guess
that I'd be interested in from some of
the projects I work on that deal with
Han Coney anemia is the idea that
acetaldehyde can be a modifier and
exacerbate or that condition and have
increased levels of acetaldehyde that
can exacerbate the Fanconi symptoms
cancer development and in blood defects
so one question that some of the
projects I work on have been trying to
figure out is are there ways to predict
what upstream events might reduce levels
of acetaldehyde and obviously you know
the data that you guys have collected
with the topological networks you might
be able to ask that question you know
what upstream if I you know one how one
to develop a drug to target a gene or a
reaction where might I look for things
that are going to ultimately decrease
the levels of acid al-qaeda in a cell or
a specific tissue so I'm just curious
about your thoughts on the feasibility
of that type of thing given the
complexity biology and the fact
you you know these are networks that
have feedback loops and crosstalk is it
even kind of feasible to expect that
that would be useful to do and are there
groups doing this or services available
that are starting to think about that
type of things I think it was really
valuable
yeah great question so so as I said when
I first started this this talk so this
is really a gentle introduction about
our project so actually we have the
rubber so are developing some really
sophisticated mathematical modeling to
try to really handle all these kind of
issues like you you you're putting the
art so one base America modeling we have
the rapids called a public graphical
model so which can integrate as islamic
data together into a pathway model and
try to relate mimic what actually
happened in the upstream for example
some mutations and as in what turns to
me effect so like in your case or if
there's a mutation happen during that
dream so we have some reward or
childhood maybe said another modeling we
have develop raises cada bully network
based modeling so we are using so-called
the fuzzy logic model basically we
integrate all this mutation possible
mutation functional impact into this has
this bully network which automatically
from our
curated on manually clear pathways and
really try to see so this is a bully
network model we actually have used the
for drug impact analysis we just
published a paper last my surgery for
this motorized the drug impact so inks
that possibly comments but I currently
all this mathematical model is still
limited to one specific pathways so
which come to this with hospital issue
so the next step we are actually trying
to work on is really build some kind of
bigger Network saying single possibly a
child connector stable or possibly
together for example as I'm we what
project we are working with the channel
is relatively under standard dragon
resistant in ml so we try to really
leage how the aggregator still hope
asthma together too
a high level Network under the in common
ISM in polyMet or galaxy or different
drugs are definitely a teaching can't do
something I guess five years ten years
no you know twenty or thirty how great a
far far away it's really like the first
obvious question is we don't have casual
specific network yet and there's a whole
cumulative we don't really have this
kind of largest scale teachers a silicon
network of hospital so you can see all
these simulation moderate is extremely
difficult if I see so and also to get a
lil a high accuracy modeling mass Mac
modeling we need clearly all these
parameters which is almost not possible
to you get for example I get for
ordinary differential equation modeling
you need an initial concentration all
these connecticut parameters it will
never be god may be in next at if
thickness VDI through mathematical cell
we will see here we will see but it is
the direction and others at the lecture
we really want going not not in the
future next five years the outcome has
to be like the magnitude of like the
decision of the outcome is just so
especially in like the case of like
patients in cancer has to be so precise
like there's not really a lot of margin
for error and the consequence of like
making the wrong decision is like
people's lives
okay yes thank you I fortunately we're
running out of time so thank you very
much and I hope to talk to you again
next time
[Applause]